all right moving on and Benjamin
Netanyahu has been sworn in as Israel's
new prime minister capping a remarkable
political comeback the veteran Leader's
sixth government will be most right the
most right-wing in Israeli history and
it includes ultra-orthodox and
ultra-nationalist parties the
administration is vowing to expand
settlements in the occupied West Bank
considered illegal under international
law
[Applause]
Israel's longest serving prime minister
has returned to power
Netanyahu has been sworn in yet again
[Applause]
and our position members of parliament
are not happy
I hear the constant cries of the
opposition about the end of the country
and democracy but to losing elections is
not the end of democracy this is the
essence of democracy
the new far-right government has vowed
to promote settlements in the occupied
West Bank
the militant group Hamas says that will
lead to more violence
movement issue a clear warning that the
policies of this incoming government
represent a trigger point for major
unrest which may extend beyond Palestine
this year is already the deadliest in
the region since 2005.
around 500 000 Israelis live in the
disputed areas alongside some two and a
half million Palestinians
this government is great news it's going
to be strong for the Jewish people in
the state of Israel
and I really hope it will not disappoint
us
Netanyahu also wants to block Iran's
efforts to develop nuclear weapons
but it's not only Regional tensions that
will be challenging the veteran leader
is still fighting corruption charges in
court and will face tough opposition at
home
well earlier I spoke with history
Professor Louis Fishman author of the
book Jews and Palestinians in the late
ottoman era claiming the Homeland and I
asked him if Benjamin netanyahu's new
Coalition would be any more stable than
previous governments
you know on the surface it actually
might look to some that it's a stable
government he got 60 63 seats he's
secure he's passed law that they can
have Breakaway groups from them but even
the first day was um I mean quite a
controversial with we saw lgbtq
protesters going out despite that you
know um appointing Amira Ohana an openly
gay man the speaker of the knesset was a
huge move but we know that there are
parties within the religious liners
party and other parties that are
extremely homophobic racist and they're
wanting to actually legislate
discrimination within of the law so what
we can see now is that you have quite a
few people even in the liquid are upset
with some of these more radical voices
emerging
um and this is just the very very
beginning you know we have a the
minister of National Security and being
there is you know openly he was he was
barred from running for years because he
was deemed a fascist and now he's going
to be in charge not just the police but
also he's going to be in charge of
accusing me of the of of the the the
security forces some of them in the West
Bank so we have a lot of things that we
need to wait and see how they play out
it doesn't it doesn't look good I'll end
by saying it doesn't look good either
when you know when one of the women uh
people or read stroke she comes out and
says you know what we want to legislate
discrimination saying that if a doctor
doesn't want to serve someone who's from
the LGBT community or Arab they don't
have to so these are these are
far-reaching changes that that Israel
has never seen before now the government
has already vowed to extend settlements
in the occupied West Bank so what does
this actually mean for stability in the
region
but this is when when the flash points
of conflict that we might see within the
government and this is simply simply
because they are now trying to work with
peace for Saudi Arabia and it seems that
not according to the news tonight it
seems that Netanyahu got a okay from
being there and smoke treats not to the
two more far-right people not to push
for annexation but this is something
that is inherent in the in the far right
so how will he be able to you know
please both sides uh by building more
settlements this is going to also
problematize relations with the United
States but we have to remember that the
last government also built more
settlements so for Palestinians for the
everyday Palestinian this is not going
to be a major shift the last government
which was considered liberal more
Palestinians actually died
um by Israeli Army gunfire then during
the Netanyahu years then the decade
before I mean based on the year so we're
gonna have to wait and see this this
what how this plays out settlements
could problematize
relations United States definitely I
would say and they need the U.S support
right now
Louis Fishman historian and writer thank
you